a
British Iranian dual National
I know that the thoughts of the whole
house will be with his wife and two
daughters at the time of their loss
they have shared his ordeal an ordeal
which began just over three years ago
when he was lured back to Iran he was
detained and then subject to the
notorious and arbitrary legal process of
the regime
before his death Mr akbari described
what was done to him and how torture had
been used
let there be no doubt he fell victim to
the political vendettas of a vicious
regime his execution was the cowardly
and shameful Act of a leadership which
thinks nothing of using the death
penalty as a political tool to silence
dissent and settle internal scores
in February last year Mr agbari's family
asked the foreign Commonwealth and
development office for our support and
we have worked closely with them ever
since
I want to pay tribute to their courage
and their fortitude throughout this
terrible period in line with their
wishes my Noble friend Lord Ahmed the
minister of State lobbied Iran's most
senior Diplomat in the UK as soon as we
learned that Mr akbari's execution was
imminent we maintained the pressure
right up until the point of his
execution but sadly to no avail
when we heard of the tragic news on
Saturday morning we acted immediately to
demonstrate our revulsion
I ordered the summoning of Iran charged
Affair to the foreign Commonwealth and
development office to make clear the
strength of our feeling our ambassador
in Tehran delivered the same message to
a senior foreign Ministry official ten
other countries have publicly condemned
the execution including France Germany
and the United States the European Union
has done the same and I am grateful for
their support at this time
we then imposed sanctions on Iran's
prosecutor General Muhammad Jafar
Montessori who Bears heavy
responsibility for the use of death
penalty for political ends
his designation is the latest of over 40
sanctions imposed by the UK on the
Iranian regime since October including
six individuals linked to the
Revolutionary courts which have passed
egregious sentences against protesters
including the death penalty
in addition I have temporarily recalled
his Majesty's Ambassador Simon
shircliffe from Tehran for consultations
and we met and discussed this earlier
today now we should consider what
further steps alongside our allies we
take to counter the escalating threat
from Iran we do not limit ourselves to
the steps that I have already announced
Mr akbari's execution follows Decades of
pitiless repression by a ruthless regime
Britain stands with a brave and
dignified people of Iran as they demand
their rights and freedoms
just how much courage that takes
is shown by the appalling fact that over
500 people have been killed
and 18
000 have been arrested during a recent
wave of protests
instead of listening to the calls for
change within Iran the regime has
resorted to its usual tactics of blaming
Outsiders and lashing out against its
supposed enemies including by detaining
a growing number of foreign Nationals
for political gain
today there are many European Nationals
being held in Iranian prisons on
spurious charges including British dual
Nationals and I pay tribute to our staff
both in Tehran and here in the UK who
continue to work tirelessly on their
behalf and to secure their release
and Beyond its borders the regime has
supplied Russia with hundreds of armed
drones used to kill civilians in Ukraine
across the Middle East Iran continues to
inflict Bloodshed and destruction by
supporting extremist militias and all
the while
the steady expansion of the Iranian
nuclear program is threatening
International Peace and security and the
entire system of global
non-proliferation in the last three
months alone
Britain has imposed five separate
packages of sanctions on Iran and today
we enforce designations against over 300
Iranian individuals and entities
we have condemned the regime in every
possible International Forum securing
Iran's removal from the United Nations
Commission on the status of women and
alongside our partners creating a new UN
mechanism to investigate the regime's
human rights violations during these
recent protests
but the house should be in no doubt
that we are witnessing the vengeful
actions of a weakened and isolated
regime obsessed with suppressing its own
people debilitated by its own fear of
losing power and Wrecking its
International
reputation our message to that regime is
clear the world is watching you and you
will be held to account particularly by
the brave Iranian people so many of whom
you are oppressing and killing and I
commend the statements to house